First, we have to keep a couple things in mind. I have to decide what variable
I'm going to use for the angle. I'm going to let a equal the measure of the
angle. Next, I have to remember what supplement and complement mean. If you
recall, the supplement of an angle, I'll write it as s, is equal to 180 minus
the measure of the angle. So here, we have the supplement as 180 minus the
measure of the angle. The other thing we have to remember is the complement. The
complement of an angle is 90 degrees minus the measure of the angle. So, I have
the measure of the angle is a. The supplement is 180 minus a, and the complement
is 90 minus a. Now, we can try to turn the words into an equation. The
supplement of the angle s measures, which means equals, 30 degrees more. So
that's 30 plus twice it's compliment. I know that s equals 180 minus a, and I
know that the compliment is 90 minus a. Now I can solve the equation for a. The
first thing we need to do to solve this equation is to distribute this 2. So I
have 180 minus a equals 30 plus 2 times 90 is 180. And 2 times negative a is
negative 2 a. The next thing I want to do combine these like terms. 180 plus 30
is 210. I need to get all my variables onto one side of the equation, and I'm
going to do that by adding 2 a to both sides of the equation. When I add 2 a to
both sides of the equation, the left side I have 180. Negative a plus 2 a gives
me a. And that's going to equal 210. The next thing I need to do is subtract 180
from both sides. And I get a equals 210 minus 180 which gives me 30. So, the
measure of an angle who's supplement measures 30 degrees more than twice it's
complement is 30 degrees. I think we've had enough of word problems for now.
Let's move on to something else.